after all I'm with my co-presenter Chris
known as chess explained hi Chris Yeah
right Trevor okay we had game for today
and we're in for a bit of excitement as
far as openings are concerned it kicked
off with Island plain white he played be
four so no sloth defense thankfully yeah
back to back to the roots here yeah I'm
just didn't you fall play all his life
but recently Wendy for often in those
matches and some specific games where he
sort of thought this would be the better
idea hmm but the first time in this
match and also surprised not no dull
super solid system with e five but
actually Sicilian defense which which
you know is an exciting defense there's
that nothing much more exciting than
Sicilian as that yeah well well II fiber
is a matter of the line you play of
course I play your fire for so I'm
basically all the time on nany for but I
don't play sodala think it's just a
matter of shooting the lines but Gavin
usually then place the Petrov and tries
to really draw at so the same is good
news here and the second slide surprise
also is coming here like directly on
move to yes because some girl friend is
maybe yeah maybe is here after Kasparov
retrying the world's number one expert
on the on the night off but he doesn't
doesn't play it he plays 96cm d6 would
have yeah yeah in the night off I I used
to play this when I was a kid this
resnikoff I had I was huge in the
enthusiastic about it because I thought
it sounded good you know it's a jerk-off
you know sound like Russian and um and
there was a lot of theory on it and I
think part of the reason I stopped
playing is so when you play the Sicilian
in UK unfortunately people play things
like c3 and stuff and all sorts of
avoiding lines are also of course Bishop
b5
new auntie's fresh dick off well in the
last few years yeah i'm also on move 393
is also getting popular 93 here just to
avoid this hmm because black now if he
wants to go for the fresh new coffee
would have need to yeah you could
actually play six with the tricky
transposition maybe but Knight f6 would
be the straight move to select this
Reznikoff option after d 4 but after 96
white can play em interestingly e5 or
Bishop b5 and both are quite dangerous
alright so well it's a it's an
interesting way to to avoid the trash
Nica Fiona move three especially Bishop
b5 has gained I think almost equal
status on compared to deform well almost
other top players almost any entire
Sicilian this is rated as a second-rate
opening but which should be fine for
that that's just may be equally good as
de 40 it's considered on an equal term
so the same yeah so yeah it's
understandable i played this is three
and also a lot in lime a couple of years
ago and you get those sidelines very
often neck c3 and 93 whatever and then
it's a bit almost a bit off-putting
because you invest quite some time to
study the interesting a symmetrical
positions you you would get and then
someone plays a rather bleak sideline
but usually you don't have so much
problems then to get a decent game it's
just a matter of attitude i think to
handle those his reasoned and stuff if
you place a second red line then you
should be glad actually but it's a no
it's not like it's not this reason why i
stopped airplane syrian but um and so
it's it's it's 11 irritating thing to ya
have to worry about all those other
lines young but nothing here he just
plays d for the principled young move
I think apparently girl fan has played
this in his past this resnick on anyway
about 10 years ago yeah he played it as
a sort of yeah back up line or whatever
I met but there shouldn't be so many
games maybe I know like it doesn't I
didn't look it out I know he played it
but not not like all the time it's no
known um huge expert on this but of
course sir he will have fun than some
some pretty pretty nice preparation okay
so after C takes d4 Knight takes e4 we
have Knight f6 which prompts night see
free to make sure Knight c3 is played
because if black was a totally different
line if I five actually because here
white can still have this or even well
by playing like f6 so you can avoid them
Roxy um binds yeah wyd would have time
to a place you form and this if I've is
perfectly okay him it's just a different
line but it doesn't really force Knight
c3 like it is done here yeah and i knowi
five and clear white doesn't have much
choice right db5 other more so really
really are nothing hmm let me to show it
briefly why this night goes on this
route if white goes let's say night be
three or Knight f3 black has just Bishop
before and at d5 the next move yes and
you get you get in d5 and you have fun
yeah you can debate if black is already
better but it so it doesn't have any
problems yeah so um so night b5 db5 is
the most critical so these nights kind
of stumbling around the tracks as me you
know when I was much younger to play
this flash mob because I just thought
well actually interestingly you can get
the bishop pair on a gphone except
double pawns and you just use like all
the imbalances but um there's another
way for white to play this without so
many um so many interesting imbalances
as we'll see so after d6 Bishop g4
yeah and I think no a six him attacking
the night so night a frightening looks
maybe some people might be surprised by
this but this is all free because the
night is heading sometimes to that d 5
square once this pawn moves when yes
night moves then this ball moves reroute
it also just a matter of yeah lack of
alternatives white certainly would
prefer to FS night on e 30 or somewhere
else not on a three but well this is the
reason why this opening is playable this
kind of time loss by whites night
otherwise black will just be busted in
the long run with all his weaknesses but
it's just a matter of time here that
white needs to spend to get this night
back into play yeah and yeah now be five
threatening immediately before yeah
piece of white needs to take some strong
measures here and this is other night 35
which are not place and this is the
young maybe not strategical option yeah
and now now here um well the other
option was bishop was it is it here
Bishop takes f6 am I yeah this then yes
jtags is usually played not not Queen
takes um II because this is this was on
it too noisy five of tempo yeah yeah
black camp is just too much time so
there's NC 4 yeah i know no 95 and this
is the line i used to really like and i
want some great games in the past you
get the bishop power in that g file and
it's very good fun the imbalances there
yeah this is really is very interesting
to play for black even especially if you
like yeah active piece plate if you if
you're sort of from a fan of solid very
nice pond structures then is not not not
your kind of chess but it's a it's very
interesting to play black no place at
five or Bishop g7 these are the tools
that you can play
and while this double porn is no issue
it get gets um yeah it gets traded off
with f5 you have to F points to fight
for the center and yeah it's a it's very
interesting this is a sharp option but I
think um recently why didn't go so much
for this so maybe like has has some
resources there that puts why them off
from the surf from the slide so this is
a comma option just 95 yeah not changing
portraiture too much so after Bishop e7
just taking on f6 giving up the dark
square Bishop to increase the dominance
of of the nights on and and control of
d5 in general but now here this is
interesting that C free used to be
popular but now SI falls more popular
yeah for i'm not sure i'm no expert but
whenever i see this rustic off plate on
the top level game they usually go for
this line I'm very often at the top you
don't even get this opening because
people will play on move three Bishop b5
or play 93 so they want this Reznikoff
it has very really good theoretical
understanding i think so but whenever
they play the open sicilian actually
then and it gets especially cough are
usually they they go through this
position so it seems like what considers
to be a relatively relatively safe way
to well probe around a bit not too much
risk taking and maybe get something if
like there's something stupid so on yeah
i think before now is so it's the main
move it doesn't make much sense to take
on c4 to get why tonight into into the
game immediately i think yeah and also
sometimes this c5 square is important
too black for me i hide yeah this can be
a nice place ideally for for bishop but
this is difficult to achieve but
sometimes you get a nightmare vrba 275
or sometimes even a queen so yeah like
has got some dark square play well why
does this nice night and some space
advantage so castles yeah and now G free
actually I think G free well there's no
problem at the moment with c4 being
victimized anytime soon so the bishop
can afford maybe two go to g 3g 2g two
so g free interesting it sort of
increases a grip on d5 yeah and it sort
of anticipates that leg maybe it's not
really the kind of position where you
need to play this as black but legs f5f
705 as usual plan and the bishop on g2's
it's just perfectly placed to defuse
this plan as then with the Foursquare
would be yeah wait for the bishop so
yeah it sort of tries to limit like even
more and what the alternative would be a
vision e 2 and Queen d3 stuff like this
but g3 looks pretty ammonius and also
you might have the idea to on the board
speed okay you might have the idea to
play h4 at some point this is also often
an idea right so and like H for
non-visual g5 can be a response some
positions now okay but black just plays
a 5 GQ spawn on before yeah now our
Bishop g2 yeah Bishop g4 so this
prepares for fi potentially but
otherwise the bishop is still useful on
this diagonal yeah I think also what
black need to consider a year he plays
Bishop b6 next move so let's just put it
on the board castles and be sure to be 6
yeah and if the bishop would still be on
f6 white maybe could capture the end
that captured e 69 f6 Queen f6 oh yes
yes no so maybe prepare some if it
should be six in a way
I think it's really a loss of a pawn
quite sometimes you can sacrifice this
point but I don't think in this position
just not the right setup of this so yeah
we arrived here and white 193 attribute
to different yeah yeah and yet next move
really a surprise me but it's just um
maybe it's just okay yeah um like took
on d5 which you would think if white can
keep a piece on d5 that would be more
ideal than a pawn but I wonder about um
so he played actually see takes d5 here
but i wonder if we played queen takes d5
instead yeah what would be going on here
interesting maybe maybe there is a porn
sack available with Queen B 6 i'm not
entirely sure ah yeah this is suddenly
all said why I would consider the black
would consider sorry now be 60 so Queen
d6 now you could rub the aid then c5
maybe but then you can just drop the
Queen back everything else fails and it
doesn't have a square on d6 yes that's
trapping yelling yeah so maybe could be
six assume the right way to to start
here and I guess ok it's d5 exploitable
here for a night well the bishop eyeing
III the night can't wrote there so it's
a case of a route an access route which
I've been talking about recently in some
recent videos if there's no access route
to is d5 really an exploitable weakness
because the bishops kind of a bit
passive on g2 I mean it's not I don't
think this would be a major problem t5
anyway in this position as soon as night
moves Knight d4 is also gonna be
powerful for black as well so yeah so
maybe that's why white was content just
a block of a pawn see takes d5 just a
funny little line that I saw let's put
25 on the board again quickly just to
show
tricky a queen v6 yeah with the six-year
move now and yeah and let's let's let's
just continue this line let's say I'm I
know worked you want sorry I've just
after this I don't know on Queen v6
rookie one on crimson sruthi one yes
yeah just just just just to show a nice
idea here let's say Roxy eight now might
can still not take because of up to
eight it's still trapped on the other
one yes oh yeah anyway then let's say be
three to prevent v3 value and then 94
this is just as literature oh very nice
i've seen this look is power of going
once this liner entrapping a piece that
you form and then they've got rook c5
yes so that Queen could be silly though
yeah yeah this is a neat little trick
but something to remember it's sometimes
possible to catch those yeah fired once
the Queen's here yeah okay it's a
certainly nothing that would happen in a
world championship game but you never
know okay yeah well still 65 I thought
oh yeah I so I think that's giving black
mobility with f5 potential potentially
later yeah also you got it no no no not
there I don't know it might be age of
course all to reroute to see Five Year
97 to c5 later yeah you wanted to see
five is if you if you get the night on
25 then you're simply better with like
yeah you have blocked this for 23 of the
Queen side and half the F porn mobile
this would be very nice and it's not
lost or something for white but he needs
to be careful can easily get ugly yeah
this um maybe in this position okay
let's not venture too far off in this
position but c5 you mean by white oh um
I will not be free um you can still
prepare maybe every if it just just take
this night or just take it that's quite
radical and then play f5 maybe maybe
that's okay all my exes night night
I'd not see 5 along loans if I took a
bit but if you get 95 know then you're
close to a strategical win here yes yeah
this mission is not that great in this
structure is it fantastic broken there's
no rushing at five year and the huge fan
of Bishops but this one I had not not
not even I am would who would think that
this is a good bishop so um yeah well I
think he takes d5 is not really on the
cards maybe I'll night be 88 could play
see fight this this would be would be
still an idea right don't might be I be
able then c5 this this is an idea for
white hmm maybe this isn't too bad
actually if we take Saudi 6 I sang all
something else yeah maybe d6 llenroc do
you one form of the locusts yeah on d 60
black will play rook somewhere a seven
roop do you want and then the problem
here it really is this stupid night on
c2 if it would be on c4 and what I would
have a brilliant position but it's not
easy to reroute but this is them it's
not not out of this vote here this is
variation this could be could be okay
for white ya got a nice bishop so mmm
yeah yeah maybe he takes d5 it isn't so
so awful if you go see 5 but it's not
not one hundred percent clear that that
black wood would play this way but they
want they want to smash coupon structure
in every game so C takes d5 we've got
cement coupon structure the 65 looks a
bit lame but okay I what I want to
understand he is if you put it on the
board seat XD 598 what I thought is that
maybe I'm important at the aid of course
not 97 because on 97 this night has no
no idea anymore
yeah because they're actually write this
f4 is out of the question so this is
hopeless sorry night to g6 as an idea
yeah yeah yeah I'm getting here is the
most important thing is that so yeah
this is the dream square for the night
plucking the C file and this would be
would be good but what I thought here I
thought maybe a white is playing on the
idea that he can play Bishop e3 at some
point controlling c8 so that black
cannot really go rook c8 and some point
I see ya make it fast oh is that usually
the fast track in here for that idea
it's an idea we'll just push my tree um
now just to show the idea thought that
white maybe would have this opportunity
to grab the c8 square and of course
black is doing the same with the bishop
on g5 but maybe you can add some I can
play a form to to break this it's risky
and I thought this would be the idea
maybe but I think it's all pointless
course blacks night gets to see 5 and
then it's just over it doesn't it your
heart is just so great m and and white
tonight is a complete complete foolish
pieces it cannot do anything on only
three it simply get exchanged all the
time yeah so you don't really have a
route to activate it so this Bishop 25
is doing a nice job here yeah you know
it's it's just nothing ok so now I wrote
that black is maybe more comfortable so
maybe that's why he wanted to just
initiate action on the queenside he
plays a free just your remaining the
structure here let's try can make you
without the flight development market
red white have but wall nada Hicks okay
okay so okay there's a slightly it seems
a vulnerable porn on the queenside for a
moment that's after a takes and of
course not takes because then you lose
the liar so night takes
then the Knights come off okay that
solves White's night issue so we have
opposite color bishops and again
symmetrical porn structure which doesn't
bode well from previous games for being
a draw but um but now h4 is used to kick
that bishop to commit it a bit more to
it goes to h6 okay and our bishop age
free so we've got symmetrical
positioning of the bishops symmetrical
porn structure opposite color bishops
this slight concern about this beep horn
maybe I mean faint concerning I don't
think it's a big deal so and also he
thinks could can be a potential point of
entry were white could if you could you
later look the electoral politics queen
on be fighters would be some pressure
yeah I'm just a managed will be pressure
on d6 but with that Bishop just making
sure see ones unavailable a route to see
six seems very hard to achieve yep the
issue really and it plays Queen d6
knowledge also avoids most like on rook
a six or queen be five this kind of
remove to activate your pieces and now
you really ask yourself or torture do I
do here yeah you want the should be
seven but i think they are best is
nothing that you can do yes now it's
interesting actually though this this
idea here of of be free that that really
does imply brooke a to making use of
that be porn for this invasor ear okay
to this peg on 80 which will force
potentially an exchange of rooks so it's
difficult to see well it looks as though
this reznikov has been a very fine
weapons again equality here but it's
just a way well again the way the
symmetrical pawn structure ended up an
obstacle bishops but um be free yeah
looks
it's good to draw it blackens will be
having two whites if we can draw back to
whites in a row aunty after this yeah
right you will have widened Game six and
Game seven and during general on a
completely young problem-free draws like
a certainty ok 44 girl frontier it is
the moral on winner I'm not sure this is
an English expression of butter yeah it
is just you can feel long as soon as
being the winner of this game like what
didn't get absolutely anything yeah yeah
so Bishop c6 though as oh maybe the a
file might be important poking at the a8
square but now just Roque too and of
course there's going to be pressure on
be too if and if the rook did leave then
Blackwood just possess that I've this
wouldn't be any good to do it would be
pointless to do rook be one yeah this
place for a loss in a way to loose
became it's not immediately obvious what
black could do but it's it's pointless
to try to win here risk something
because this mission 46 for instance it
it controls the a8 square this is nice
but other than that it's just stupid
piece doesn't do anything and black has
good ideas like rugby aids to be 42 d 4
and so on so I just needs to do to get
this get this wrapped up to draw yeah so
he takes high to and now he just goes
for that porn and protects his beep or
at the same time so protecting an
attacking okay but black doctor doesn't
want to be upon del Y pregnant before no
yes from yet before maybe two to keep
the porn and I'm 35 it'd be good because
the bishop young so yeah the very dry
but good even if he would lose the a
porn it's very dry for nothing but you
can just get it back with rugby aid
yessir rook the eights ok so after Queen
takes a two unfortunately well we have
another raw butter it was it was an
exciting opening it's it's it's the pool
instruction really the pawns of the soul
of chess philidor said that so if the
porn structure is symmetrical the soul
is less exciting of the game the
underlying soul of the game is is
defined by the porn structure yeah
butter so they drew here but ok should
we have a quick quick review all this
final position should we say something
about this this final position after
rook soy Queen every route be eight so
Queen 80 so Queen takes be too let's
imagine that they carried on I would
just be a dead draw um and if we need to
demonstrate anything here um there's
just no exploitable targets yeah I mean
wyd them get to draw what can you do I
think you know what if I would be black
and that would be facing a somewhat we
could play aware try to win I would try
to yeah exactly after you for after
would be the song it wouldn't yeah to us
if anyone then then maybe black could
could it's a draw but could try
something yeah how much she could try
but at least yeah let's do a quick recap
ians quite quite quite boring affair of
this game but its own at the same it's
not the same if maybe this Bishop takes
d5 ideas completely new or something
well at least them yeah I think the
critical point is really made of 17 so G
305 my girl found captured on d5 yeah so
pushy i'm really not sure this is a
common idea and yeah maybe white needs
to try something else 65
it's not like what some people would
with Anya white is playing for draw or
whatever of course not she tries to do
something but maybe yeah it's hard to
assess the other well yeah I used to
like to play for f5 but it seems
inappropriate with this vignette so
Bishop you're playing into whites hands
if you go to the f5 p.m. this is a step
in this kind of line Black is more
likely to play some yeah maneuvering
unkind up fer I wonder about the urgency
of Bishop d5 was actually nike free
supported by the night to be able to
recapture on it takes maybe there's an
urgency to take on d5 for no one like to
c 2 e 3 black and just always take the
bishop but you can always take with it i
don't know this point that's taken with
that night um i started to give white
much yeah ok so i think other moves have
been played in this position like
probably queen be a i think i've seen
commentary with that being mentioned as
another move and i would expect most
like a queen bed maybe I look a seven or
I don't know g six maybe mm-hmm ok so
Bishop a d5 unfortunately we get a
symmetrical pawn structure here maybe
maybe maybe this is ridiculous I'm no
expert but maybe he takes d5 nc5 would
be an idea what I would have suggested
it could be an idea to play in this
chopper but it's not it's not so not
obvious that it's so great hmm i wonder
if also to just ignore that and i could
ignore that with my I six not have to
take I was thinking about this but c6
still a nice block aye ya ya know then
it's nothing located here I mean it's a
nice night sorry it's not a nice you
know neither is not as it but I just
need to somehow a sec the exchange on
see fire you right and then these pools
do become mobile oh it's not easy
because this Bishop
g5 yeah i did this looks risky for like
yeah yeah so what I was just thinking
just add and add one idea here instead
of 98 in this position yarn after yeah
what about 90 form just quickly just
quickly thinking about this night XD for
it takes d4 24 Bishop f6 22 yeah looks
like a strong block height hair with
Queen it cream b6 here yeah there's
enough the poem might not be significant
at all this could be an idea the idea is
you know now I Bishop d4 to c5 and and
just put everything on the on the e-file
it looks very George yeah and it's a
white target you see black wouldn't have
the f7 the targets why can't use d 5 so
this bishop would be better with it than
that for a long time now this could be
an idea just an often suggestion but it
looks playable I think yeah interesting
yeah you're right Knight d4 yeah that
would avoid that would simplify to an
opposite bishop blockade scenario 94
okay but in the game we got 65 yes so we
have unfortunately symmetry ah again and
maybe sort of overestimated his chances
here to try to play go and play on the
queenside I'm not sure maybe be three be
three could be a move that he may be
missed yes be free is often use this net
to try and play efrain and gang up on a
pond there no event I met blacks blacks
b3 move from some moves later also I
just try to think what Anna may have
missed here because i think if i don't
think that it doesn't look like white
has got much improvements after she
takes d5 and if it's he wouldn't allow
such an easy draw if he can avoid it so
even in greene takes d5 we could have
played and played on for ages
but so what I think maybe maybe it's not
no not a six and then maybe he didn't
really appreciate that blanket could go
be three later so it takes be queen
tonight eggs yeah and then we got this
position with the bishop 27 and then
maybe be three maybe this is what he
missed I'm just speculating here you
know I didn't I didn't see the press
conference it's time it's so often quite
interesting of course they're they're
not telling each and every thought this
would be in too friendly to the opponent
but if white plays be free black
hasbrouck a free with greater of facts
just horrible I don't think that's good
for whites play be free to try and stop
be free yeah you need to be a bit
cautious here that's why you can you can
drift into a worse position white is the
name so the bishops trying to do
something aggressive sort of staying at
home um there's a business foursome this
kind of b3 thing otherwise why would get
da far for nothing yeah so yeah we just
drifted is it I did find it inside so
that I don't usually have games like
this when I place official cover but
theories progress some people blaming
computers in preparation for things
sometimes four drawers like this butter
yeah it looks um yeah it looks black
with blacks done a good job to secure
drove with black so he's late this is
especially xt5 a new move I think this
position who must have been played
before I could look it up myself in the
database and wait I just I just I just
that I really want to know this just
seconds because you could find her if
this was something new I just need to
cover second
okay so Bishop blue fibers pleasure
their love connection I'm sorry it just
does connection i think i cant
connection back sorry and we got
connected idea on again okay okay i
shall we cool it a day there sorry did
you have any quick news to report i'm
not sure i'm sharing screwing you but
just quickly mention my I'm just quickly
checking if this was a new idea you
should be five castles you should be the
six yeah it seems kind of a new idea I
don't try and find the exact position
which surprises me all right ah I
thought I found the position okay takes
d5 this was known this was played three
times already interesting and white and
won all three games haha blimey what did
Wi-Fi off to Bishop d5 yeah we have got
three games with Bishop takes d5 and why
it has played all three possible moves
25 CD 585 and won all three games but
again all games what was I know that's
not a favorite but ok but the sea text
if I will also played not to be eight
then H or 83 yeah well this is sometimes
you just don't understand our games that
you see okay you don't want to get to it
was kind of known but black players
played somewhat strange here so but easy
improvement I think for forgot phone
here yeah okay let's wrap it up it was a
pretty easy draw at least on the surface
for black and I think no tomorrow Guffin
will try a bit with white and he's got
two whites in row now yeah so this will
be very interesting I think up to now it
can be very satisfied with the with a
match it's not like some people yeah
suggested before that it would be the
really a landslide victory
fergie she so this you can already
forget about I think yeah yeah so it's
going to be a tense match it's a gonna
build a suit maybe offer freely okay
it's you know it's just the same if you
get to two top teams and football let's
say Champions League final and unless
nice [ __ ] with goal you've got those
technical place all the time and it's
just the boring super boring stuff
sometimes yeah it football it says no
goal and if you're going to only go you
have the other team that needs to do
something and so on so I think it really
would be helpful if if you've got some
some decisive game in this match I think
this would really spice up things a lot
but yeah they're pretty good goalkeepers
okay what okay I hope I've everyone on
you've got something out of commentary
here and and not too depressed by the
match game so far some some interesting
at least it was interesting opening
today anyway and okay thanks everyone on
YouTube and thanks Chris thanks for
watching okay comments or questions on
youtube on both our channels we upload
into both all channels kingscrusher and
chess explain channels on YouTube thanks
very much